hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i want to talk about the
rules the regulations and the
legislation
of hmos this is really important if
you're
interested in hmos you need to
understand the rules and legislation and
so many people get confused about the
difference between
planning permission licensing
article 4 selective licensing they get
it all
mixed up and they don't know whether you
need a license whether you're planning
what do you need to do
in order to buy a house turn it into a
hmo and make sure that it's legally
sound so this video is really really
important if you are interested in hmos
please do me a massive favor though
smash the like button
i literally put out a video about
property every single day
i've done hundreds of deals in property
i've been investing in property for over
a decade and i do this for
free i hardly even have adverts on my
channel so i don't hardly get paid to
really do this
this is just because i genuinely want to
help people like you succeeded property
so just do me a favor
smash the like button also subscribe to
the channel
turn the notification bell on so that
you don't miss a video
hmos what is hmo well you know what a
hmo is it's a house in multiple
occupancy where you rent it out
room by room now a licensed hmo
do you need a license for hmo let's park
planning
park article 4 park selective licensing
park everything else
let's just talk about hmo licenses and
the answer is
it depends on the size of the hmo if the
hmo
has got five or more people
that are going to be living in the hmo
you are
generally going to need a license for
that property
now this isn't always the case sometimes
it depending on the area like there are
some areas like oxford for example
that require a license even if there's
only four people
but the rule of thumb across the board
is that if there's
five or more people in the hmo
then you're gonna need a license if
there's just four people
four rooms four people you will not need
a hmo license
generally speaking now always check
on the council website to see what the
rules are in each different area because
it can vary but this is
the case nearly all of the time so
how do you get a hmo license well you
apply on the council website
do you have to wait until you get your
license
before you can start renting out the
rooms and the answer is no
you apply for the license and as soon as
you've applied
you can then start renting out the rooms
and you don't have to wait
to get the license you just have to make
sure that you apply so that's hmo
licenses
it costs around about it depends but
around about a thousand pounds to get a
hmo license
and this will last for up to uh i think
it's five
years yeah five years that will last for
so
that's a hmo license your hmo will be
accepted as a license
if the house is appropriate namely
there's fire doors smoke alarms the
bedrooms are 70 square foot
the kitchen's big enough you need half a
meter of workspace per
tenant so the house needs to be
appropriate and also you need to be
um you don't need to be an appropriate
landlord you don't need any experience
necessary to get a license but you can't
be a criminal for example
so for more details about whether a
house will apply for a license speak to
the council
you can actually get the council they'll
sometimes do it for free or they'll
charge a nominal fee
to come out to the house before you buy
it and tell you if it's appropriate for
a license or not
so i'd recommend if you can if you do
plan on getting a hmo that's licensed
i'd
recommend getting the council to come
and visit beforehand also read
on the council website the list of
requirements that
a licensed hmo in that area needs so
that's licensed
licensing is it difficult no it's
relatively straightforward
just make sure that the council are
assisting you so the property is
up to scratch next planning permission
so do you need planning permission to
turn a property
into a hmo this is entirely different
from licensing and people get so mixed
up between the two
so licensing we've talked about there is
selective licensing by the way i might
do a whole other video about that but
some areas have got selective licensing
which means that you need a license
sometimes just to own any property at
all like if you want to be a landlord in
wales
i do i am a landlord in wales if you
want to buy a house and rent it out even
just to one person
you need a license but this is this is
selective licensing selective licensing
is in
different areas it's not in every area
uh selective licensing might cost you
anywhere from
i think it's about 400 pound on average
and again that will last you for
i think it's five years but always check
okay the reason i sometimes say i think
is because
different areas do change so i don't
want to give you hard and fast figures
and and time um how long they'll last
because it can vary a little bit
so i'll do a whole separate video about
selective licensing but this is more
about hmos
listening next planning planning
planning planning planning so do you
need planning permission to turn a
property into a hmo
so generally speaking unless there's
article
4 in the area which we're going to talk
about in a moment
generally speaking you do not need
planning permission
to turn a property into a hmo unless the
property is being turned into a hmo
which has got
seven or more rooms so if you're buying
a property and you're going to be
turning it into a
from from a family home into a seven bed
hmo
you're gonna need planning permission if
it's eight nine ten you need planning
permission because it's a complete
change of use
planning from you're only planning
permission for a property where it's a
change of use
so if you're changing the way that the
property is being used you need planning
permission
so most councils would say turning a
three-bed
family home into a four-bed
hmo it's not really a big change of use
because you're just renting it out room
by room no big deal
in fact for four four rooms you're not
even gonna need a license most of the
time
that's okay planning if there's seven or
more people
you now need to put planning you need to
put a planning application in
and again you can do this with your
council you're going to put a
pre-planning application in to see what
the
what the likelihood is even before you
do that you can just call the council
and tell them your situation to get a
bit of a feel for if you're going to be
able to get planning
then you're going to put a pre-app in
and then you're going to actually get
the full planning
this is something that can be a little
bit of a process sometimes the council
can
battle you on things so a lot of
my students and a lot of the time what
i've done is i've just stuck to six bed
hmos
so you know six bed four four bed and
six bed is the sweet spot
because four beds you don't need
planning you don't need a license five
bed
you need a license six bed is the sweet
spot because you don't need planning
you're gonna need a license anyway so i
like four and six beds usually
um so that's planning permission okay
now there is an exception and that's
article four
if there's article four in an area
that's a a zone it's a direction that
the council put into certain areas
and that means that you need planning
permission which is separate from
licensing
planning permission to turn any property
into
a multi-let even if it's only a
three-bed multi-layer
three four five doesn't matter you need
planning permission so if an area is
article four you will need planning
permission
to buy a property and turn it into a hmo
this is a real pain
so i would suggest that if it's article
4 area either by existing hmos and then
just do them up and
and modernize them or move
area now if an area is article 4
and you own a property prior to article
4
coming in you're okay and you're going
to prove this by showing your ast
contracts with your tenants to
demonstrate that you've been using it
as a multi-level as a hmo prior to
article 4 coming in
in fact that's really good because then
you have the grandfather rights the
prices go up
and your competition dies so that's
planning
that's article four that's what hmo
licensing is
this might sound really complicated you
might be like oh my goodness this is
crazy there's so much rules and
legislation
the great thing about the rules and
legislation is it keeps the cowboys away
it's not that complicated when you
understand it and because hmos are
already already regulated
i don't think they're going to get any
more regulated so
we can buy hmos with confidence knowing
that when we buy them right
it's a it's a it's a strategy that's got
longevity to it
even in recessions hmos are pretty
recession-proof because as people
can't afford houses they're going to
rent rooms so i really like hmos it's
just
i've been doing hmms now for i bought my
first hmo in 2009
and i've built up quite a large
portfolio of hmos mostly in birmingham
um but i've got hmos dotted all over the
place but mostly in birmingham and the
midlands i've also
packaged and sold hundreds of hmo
properties as well
so hope this video was helpful if you've
got questions about hmos
i'd probably check out my youtube
channel on a sunday because on sundays i
do a q a
session so every single sunday and
thanks so much for watching guys please
do smash the like button
subscribe and if you want to learn more
about hmos i'll put a video just up here
where you can learn about the basics of
hmos
if you want to hear a success story of
one of my students
how they've successfully become
financially independent via hmo that you
can listen to an interview and many more
but start by by listening to this one
and please do me a massive favor and
subscribe over here as well
that'd be fantastic thanks for watching
the video i'll see you next time